like pick a man bring your kit I hope  today might be a good day hope is a  dangerous thing you have a brother in  the second Battalion yes sir they're  walking into a trap  your orders are to deliver a message  calling off tomorrow morning's attack  if you fail it will be a massacre let's  talk about this for a minutes why  we've got August across here that is the  German frontline if we're not clever  about this no one will get to your  brother  Oh will  there's only one way this ends  Last Man Standing  [Music]  we need to keep moving come on  how possibly make it that way man you  bloody insane  [Music]  if you don't get there in time  [Music]  we will lose 1,600 men your brother  among them good luck  you